i'm not getting back into hollywood
i'm getting into bollywood
[Music]
are you kidding me dude
have you seen bollywood
you seen it
dude
you seen it
i know indians have seen it and asians
have seen it but whites
blacks
you seen it
oh dude there's barely any scenes where
both
feet
of the main character are on the ground
together
[Music]
they're either dancing or kicking or
jumping on dudes [ __ ] yeah dude that's
what i want and i swear to god
85 of the time they're [ __ ] smiling
and 15 of the time they're crying do it
and that is the kind of movie i want to
be it's a [ __ ] soap opera that is
also the matrix dude i
it is my life's goal to be in a [ __ ]
bollywood movie dude i watch this movie
rrr on
uh on netflix it's called rrr i don't
even know what it stands for it doesn't
matter dude and i watch the movie like
this
oh my god dude the first scene i'm in
the first scene
i'm in and let me tell you why dude the
main first of all i don't even know if
it's in you could
ask me
when you see me
hey was that movie in english or not
i don't know and i saw the whole thing
got no clue
dude no clue
zero clue if it was in english or not i
think maybe it was but also i'm pretty
sure it wasn't dude
and if it wasn't english it was
they did the weirdest [ __ ] thing with
like dub over a dude that's already
speaking english with another dude that
speaks english i guess better
it just sounds like it's a children's
show but the guy will be like we need to
get our warriors and go and the [ __ ]
guys the line is like we need to get our
warriors and and spread out on the field
and the [ __ ] way it sounds is we need
to get our warriors and set out on the
field
and then so the first scene is dude it
opens up this movie r-r opens up dude
and the guy's like
there's a mob there's an angry mob is
this on netflix and there's an angry mob
trying to get into this fortress i don't
know what it is dude i don't even know
you know they're just trying to get into
a fortress and i'm like okay i'm
watching and i'm just involved with it
okay
i turn it on just cuz right
um and so i play it and then and then it
starts and then they're like there's a
mob and they're trying to get in the
fortress and the general is like we
better hold you know we better [ __ ]
we will better keep our eyes on and
there's
there's army [ __ ] guys soldiers on
the inside of the thing they're just
waiting for in order and then somebody
in the mob takes a [ __ ] like
a rock or it's not a rock it's like a
clump of dirt and throws it and it hits
something on the inside of the fortress
and the and the leader guy sees it and
he says
get him or something and one
guy's
feet
one
soldier's feet leaves the ground dude
and he jumps over the fence like a human
can do it can't but this is bollywood
leaps over the fence and
the guy is [ __ ] four football fields
away and he just fights the whole mob
the whole mob chokes people out breaks
her arms
and gets to the guy and carries him back
and then leaps over the thing and then
just there's [ __ ] 40 000 people just
takes on 40 000 people not like 10 guys
[ __ ] john wick dude this guy takes on
40 000 indians and he does it
and this is the best part about [ __ ]
bollywood
this is the best part about bollywood is
these guys are superheroes
but they make zero mention of any super
powers and that's the kind of [ __ ]
movie that i'm into dude they do not
they do not have
they don't have like the scene where
they're like well with this power we
wield like dude it's it's it's none of
that [ __ ] it's just some guy who will be
talking to a chick and then all of a
sudden
jump off the back of a horse and his
feet
never touch the ground for 33 more
minutes dude and the song is just all
like
and he just kicks [ __ ] indian
[ __ ] in
just beanie
oh dude and i never know which guy is
which guy because i'm racist i guess
dude it is so ill though bollywood is
where it's at and if i'm not in
bollywood
before i take my last breath
i have failed okay
i want to go to india and be in it i
don't care what part
india
your boys for higher and i'll take
[ __ ] less rupals or whatever kind of
[ __ ] money you guys have
you know what i'm talking about
forget it man
i love it dude oh dude and they s oh oh
and if that's not enough
they also sing
[Music]
they had to go ahead and make it my
favorite oh
hey
[Music]
it's also a musical
hey
sorry to interrupt you sir
yes
it's also a musical
what
dude and they dance dude and they do the
kind of dancing where the like the i
don't know how to describe it but they
do like did they twist the feet like
this and they're always smiling dude i
mean dude and they fight tiger it's
unbelievable
it's unbelievable if you have a problem
and
in flight and like a [ __ ] the landing
mechanism can't work and the wheel can't
go down you get a bollywood actor to fly
up there and [ __ ] push the wheel down
and let the plane land on him bollywood
can do that man i don't know why they
don't make it and then i realized
you know for some reason
the bollywood [ __ ] is way better like
it's basically like the only other
people who make movies like this are
um
like asians make i mean you know it's
asian but asians make movies like this
but it's a little bit more like this is
badass and not funny right like asians
will make movies whether japanese are
korean and it's like okay they're not
really superheroes but they're [ __ ]
um
there's no humor about it and the
bollywood [ __ ] just rides the line of is
this humorous or not but it's still kind
of badass but these guys are having such
legit fun when they're doing that
and there's dances there's dance offs in
it so basically there's the asians that
make it too and then there's like the
fast and furious movies from america and
they just are not as good for some
reason and i think it's because there's
no humor in it you know it's just like
we're family and like you gotta believe
that and be a dumb [ __ ] guy in the
theater and be like dude you know what
it actually really is about family
though i mean i know this movie like the
cars are flying from one building to
another and yeah it's not realistic
because one [ __ ] dodge viper just
jumped onto a [ __ ] crane and swung
into a hotel but honestly
it really though is about family if you
read between the lines
and you don't have to read between the
lines because vin diesel is saying that
too
the diesel's fat um so um yeah dude
just kicking [ __ ]
indian
[ __ ]
in
i want to be in it there's [ __ ] oh
man
the white dudes in the [ __ ] bollywood
movies are bad guys too
just bad guys they have like one they
have one guy that i kind of recognized
he was probably in a james bond movie
and [ __ ] and he was just like the worst
guy of all time he literally like took a
[ __ ] uh
uh
branch tree branch and [ __ ] smacked
it into like a uh
a child and
[ __ ] look it's just really violent
man but man do they dance their [ __ ]
asses off and i'm in [ __ ] bollywood
now i guess so all good man bollywood
i swear to god if i'm not in a bollywood
movie just know i failed before i take
my last breath if i'm not in a bollywood
movie i felt crazy
crazy
[Music]
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy crazy
[Music]